اسماء جلال نجمه في صعود من سنوات وتفجرت
في الهرش السابعه هو اليسا واصاله على خط
الجدل حول اللاجئين في لبنان وبين وعود
سخيه وسر الباته حنان مطاوع تثبت موقعها
كنجمه للادوار الصعبه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اسمع جلال نجمه من نجمات الجيل الحالي
للمعين جدا في السنوات الاخيره مجموعه
اعمال ونجاحات حقيقيه ما حد يقدر ينكرها
عم يخلي بالك من زيزي للكبير للسوتس
بالعربي للغرفه 207 وقبل كل دول برضو
سنوات من الاعمال لكن هذا الرمضان نقدر
نقول انه وبدون مبالغه يعني انه شفنا
امامنا كلنا موهبه اسماء جلال بتتفجر في
الهرشه السابعه المسلسل اللي بتلعب فيه
دور سلمى عانت كطفله من اهلها وبتحاول
تتخلص من هذه الحمل اللي شالته بسببهم
واللي في نفس الوقت بتتزوج من شريف اللي
هو علي قاسم وبنشوف سوا العقبات اللي
بيخوضها زواجهم
ايه بقى حركه انت ما اتعود تعملها على طول
الوعي شكله يدي غياب
الليله دي
الهرش السبعه من مسلسلات ال15 حلقه
والانتهى عرضه من ايام وماخذ اصداء
واشادات واسعه خصوصا مع تطرقوا لمواضيع
حساسه او خط شخصيه اسماء في المسلسل سلطه
الضوء علم اواضيع مهمه وحساسه كمان ومن
اول ما بدا عرض المسلسل حتى نهايته من
ايام والارشادات باسماء جلال ماليه
المنصات خصوصا كمان الكلام عن النضج
والتطور اللي الجمهور لامسوا عمل بعد عمل
وهتنضم الينا النجمه اسماء جلال اهلا فيك
معنا يا اسماء منورتنا اليوم وكل عام
وانتم طبعا بالف خير وانت بخير يا رب
دايما اهلا اهلا بيكي اسماء يعني
صعب اوصف اللي انت عملتيه في رمضان هذا
لانه نحن اللي تابعنا المسلسل واللي الناس
اللي لازم يشوفوه بقول لهم لازم يتابعوا
المسلسل صراحه يعني انت اخدتينا مع مشاعر
مختلفه بين بين
الزعل بين الحزن بين مشاكل الاهل بين
الجرح يعني قديش فعلا هذا الدور كان صعب
حسيت
يعني خليني اقول لك قبل اي حاجه انا
مبسوطه ان انت تفرجتيه ومبسوطه من فعلا
ناس قوي
الدور ده كان فعلا صعب بس
هو بسيط في نفس الوقت عشان اكون صريحه
يعني هو هو اهم حاجه ان هو كان يطلع زي ما
بيقولوا لحم ودم ان هو يبان انه دي بني
ادمه طبيعيه عاشت او تجربه
وبتطلع بتطلع منها في اوقات فجاه غصب عنها
في حاجات غصب عنها فجاه بتفكرها بحاجه مش
لازم بقى نقعد كل حاجه نقولها في خطوط او
في كلام ممكن يبان في نظره ممكن يبان في
في حاجه وكريم الشناوي شاطر قوي في ان هو
يوضح ده
عندك مشاهد يعني بتكوني فيها مع علي قاسم
يعني فعليا مشاهد من الحياه يعني مثلا هو
بيقول شيء ما بيعجبك نظره عينك او لفت وشك
بتكفي يعني كيف بتاخذي نفسك كده بكفي هذا
انه يدينا الاحساس انه نفس كلنا عايشين ده
المشهد مع ازواجنا بالضبط
بس مش مشاهدي انا وعلي قاسم بس لما حد حتى
بيتكلموا على مشاهد بين امينه وشاهين
وبيقولوا انه المشهد ده بالظبط واحنا
بنتخانق انا دي اكتر جمله بجد بتفرحني بحس
انه اوكي احنا عملنا حاجه حقيقيه او حاجه
وصلت للناس في المطبخ بتاعها قصدي هي كانت
حقيقيه صراحه زياده عن اللزوم يعني
الحقيقه لانه كلنا شعرنا فيها او مستت
فينا شيء هل في هذه الشخصيه في اي ملامح
بتشبهك يعني زينا كلنا لقينا نفسنا في بعض
الشخصيات وفي بعض الت صرفات او بعض
المواقف انت كاسماء
لا هي مش شبه هي هي هو عشان انا امثل اي
شخصيه لازم احاول اربط
خيط بيني وبينها عشان الخيط ده ممكن يبقى
مجرد ان انا تخيلت يعني ممكن ابقى اتخيلت
بس قعدت فتره طويله قوي اتخيل هي مرت بايه
عشان انا مهما حاولت امثل الاحساس بتاعها
عمري ما هعرف امثله لازم احسه فانا لازم
اتخيل هي البنت دي مرت بايه بجد وهي صغيره
قد ايه ثابت قد ايه حست كم مره ان ما حدش
عايزها ولا حد متمسك بها فكل الاحاديث دي
لازم ابقى حقيقي متخيلاها واربطها بحاجات
شبه الحاجات الموجوده بالفعل عشان احس
بالوجع بتاعتك لكن لا مش شبهي وفي اشياء
يمكن لعبته يعني على خط يعني خلينا نقول
صعب يعني مثلا طرحته وبكل جراه مثلا قصه
المساكنه هذا الشيء ما اقلقك
ما اقلقنيش لسبب بسيط جدا انه سواء انا
لما باجي اقدم دور انا مش بقول اسماء جلال
بتؤمن بايه او ضد ايه او مبادئها ايه او
افكارها ايه جلال بتقدم دور هي بين قوسين
ممثله هي لازم تتجرد من كل الحاجات وتدخل
تمثل جاهزه لان هي توصل صوره من الواقع هو
ده الغرض من الفم في الاول وفي الاخر سواء
في افلام زمان سواء في الافلام دلوقتي في
المسلسلات انا
بجسد حاجه بتحصل في الحقيقه بقول انه ده
نموذج موجود في الحياه لكن ده مالوش اي
علاقه باسماء جلال بتؤمن بايه او سبورت
بدعم ايه او ضد ايه يعني فاهمه قصدي
فاهمه عليكي طب بس مثلا انت في هالموضوع
مثلا ايش رايك
رايي انا في المساكنه مثلا
يعني انا حاسه ان هي بس حاجه حساسه قوي ان
انا اقول رايي فيها يعني حاسه انه
الموضوع ما يخصنيش يعني هي الموضوع بعيد
عني اوي بس كان ممثله اه امثل دور زي ده
لكن
لا كويس لا رد رد ذكي ممتازه يا اسماء طيب
كمان واحده من الاشياء الثانيه
شعور الارتياح يعني الناس بين المسلسلات
اللي هي الجري وخطف وضرب ومش عارفه كله في
بصفه عامه في المسلسل نفس اللي عملتوه في
خلي بالك من زيزي برضو اللي هو نجح برضو
نجاح كبير في الناس عندها كان شعور
بالارتياح صح بيتفرجوا على مشاكل بس
مبسوطين ايش سر هذه المعادله تحسي
انا بحس ان ده بيرجع لكريم الشناوي ومريم
نعوم ودايما الناس اللي بيختاروهم ان
الناس دي مش بالمره يشتغلوا مع بعض الناس
دي تقريبا ثالث او رابع مره يعملوا مشروع
ودائما في في طاقه انت بتدخلي الاستوديو
مش بتدخلي ستوديو اللي هو التصوير العادي
الطبيعي تدخلي لبيتك التاني او بيتك
الاولاني لان احنا بنشوف بعض اكتر ونشوف
اهلنا وده فعلا
الاحساس اللي احنا حاسينه بقى لنا كذا يوم
انه احنا خلصنا المسلسل بس حاسين اللي هو
ايه ده احنا هنصحى من النوم مش مش هندخل
نسلم على شاهين وامينه وعلي وكريم ونصبح
على مريم ففي في حاله دفء كده معينه بتبقى
متواجده انا برجع يعني لو هشكر حد هشكر
كريم الشناوي فيها لان هو بيتمسك بالتيم
بتاعه مهما كانت الظروف فكره
انت رجعتي لعيلتك تصوري ايوه واحنا صراحه
كان واصلنا هذا الاحساس وكمان يعني برده
اللي هو شيء برضه مغاير انتوا بتعملوه
اللي هي فكره انه مش ضروري نعمل 30 حلقه
مش ضروري نلزم الناس بقصه 30 حلقه بتحسي
هذا الشيء اريح ولا كانكم بتخرجوا من
السباق في نصه
بس انا لا مش باحس حاجه انا ما عنديش اي
اي خوف ان انا يفوتني حاجه في ده لانه
طالما لو لو احنا عندنا حدوته حلوه ووصلت
للناس واقول لك على حاجه ده يمكن اصعب ان
انت توصل حاجه وتخلي الناس تتفرج وتحكم
وتقول رايها في 15 حلقه ده اصعب لانه 30
انت هتقدر تقعد تعيد وتزيد انا مش ضد ال30
انا عادي انا انا لسه مخلصه مسلسل برده 30
حلقه قريب على حسب الحدوته ما اقدرش اقول
انا بافضل ايه كاسماء بس انا حاسه لو في
15 حلقه او عشر حلقات او حتى خمسه وحدوتها
حلوه وهتوصل للناس ومع ناس تقدر توصل
الحاجه دي
بصوره واقعيه وحقيقيه ناس تصدقها ليه لا
بالعكس هتبقى حاجه وابسط يعني
اخذت لفه كده في همم يعني من باب الفضول
يعني صراحه وحب الاستطلاع في انستجرام
وشفت ههه طبعا من الحساب اصلا مفتوح
والحساب حلو ومليان صور حلوه يعني ما
يحتاج اقول يعني شيك وحساب
شيكوا حساب اسماء على انستقرام الصور مره
حلوه طيب وبشوف التعليقات طبعا في مديح
وفي نقد اكيد كمان وفي تعليقات اللي هي
برضو مزعجه قديش بتزعجك هذا النوع من
التعليقات اللي مثلا بتكون
خالص اصل انا هاقرا كم كومنت وبعدين انا
معظم الوقت انا ما ببقاش اه انا بحاول
اتابع وابقى اللي هو مع الناس بتابع
ارائهم او ردود افعالهم وده بيبقى في
التوقيت اللي عندي فيها حاجه بتتعرض لكن
انا مش شخص فاضي لهذه الدرجه ان انا اقعد
اقرا تعليق تعليق من الناس وبصراحه بصراحه
انا عملت كده هتجنن لانه افرض انا
صدقت الكلام اللي هم كاتبينه يعني في
الاول بصراحه كنت اللي هو ببقى مركزه قوي
في كل كومنت بيتكتب واللي هو ايه ده الناس
دي متضايقه مني ليه طب انا عملت طب ممكن
الشخص ده اللي بيكرهني بكره الصبح لو
شافني في حته هيجي يتصور معايا عادي فانا
عمري ما هعرف حقيقه المشاعر فبالتالي
نتجاهلها ونشوف وقت
التصوير ده الناس دي هتتفاعل ازاي وده
اللي هيبقى الحقيقي طيب انا بس قبل ما
نختم معاكي اسماء اول شيء حابه اعلق انه
يعني اقول الكلام اللي قلت لك اياه تحت
الهوا انه انت ما شاء الله جميله جدا وانا
لما اول ما تكلمنا قبل الهوى انا واسماء
سالتها بكل صراحه قلت لها اسماء انت ايش
حاطه على وجهك تفضلي يا اسماء قولي
للجمهوري حاطه على وشك انا حاطه انا ممكن
اطلع لكم الحاجات
هتطير اعلان للبرانز بس اذا بتحبي لا خلاص
طب انا حاطه يعني احطها كونسيلر ايوه
حاطه بلاشر وحاطه ماسكره وبس
والحلو حلو يا اسماء ما يحتاج نقول يعني
شكرا لك ومنورتنا انا بس يعني ايه حبيت
انه اوضح انه ما شاء الله عليك قديش طالعه
حلوه وعلى طبيعتك يعني اسماء تجنن تجنن
تجنني في هذا العمل صراحه رائع رائع رائع
رائع يعني اعتقد من بعده خلاص انت يعني في
مرحله ثانيه تماما الان في حياتك صراحه
كلنا حبينا دورك صراحه وادائك فبشكرك جدا
وهنا فريق العمل كله حتى يعني في غرفه
التحكم كمان بيوجهوا لك تحياتهم لك
وبيقولوا لك المسلسل كمان رائع فشكرا لك
يا اسماء نورتينا اليوم كانت معنا النجمه
اسماء جلال
[موسيقى]
اليسا واصاله طبعا نجمتين كبار ممكن نقول
انه احد القواسم المشتركه بينهم انهم
يعبروا عن رايهم وجهات نظرهم باي موضوع
وبكل اريحيه وما بيفرق معهم سواء سياسيه
اجتماعيه يعني ايا كان والساعات الماضيه
النجمتين كانوا وسط جدل بيتعلق بملف
اللاجئين في لبنان اليسا معروفه من زمان
بدنا بتايد عوده اللاجئين لبلادهم
وبالتزامن مع التوتر الايام الماضيه
واطلاق عشرات الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان على
اسرائيل وقالت اسرائيل انه مجموعات
فلسطينيه وراء هذا الاطلاق وسط كل هذا
اعاده اليس التاكيد على موقفها وهذا الشيء
عملته عبر اعاده تغريد كثير تغريدات بتدعو
لعوده اللاجئين لبلادهم وبعض هذه
التغريدات لصحفيين اللبنانيين كبار ولمن
رجع الكلام عن ارائها هذه وطلعت اصوات
تايد واصوات تنتقد مثل العاده ردت اليسا
بتغريده مباشره وقالت فيها ان هي بتحب
وطنها ومصلحتها يعني ما بحياتها قللت من
احترام
الشعب وخاصه شعب عربي بتنتمي له وانما
بتعتقد انه في اي اهانه لمن تطلب عوده
مواطنين لبلادهم لانه وطن الانسان كرامته
ومن بعدها بساعات رواد تويتر شافوا تغريده
لاصاله كمان عن نفس الموضوع وبنقول فيها
اصاله بانه كلنا في الارض لاجئين وما حد
بيملك اي مكان في اي ارض كلنا زوار مهما
طالت زيارتنا وانه بدنا نرحم بعد لانه ما
في شيء بيرحمنا الدنيا صعبه وظروف الناس
صعبه وقالت ما احد حط فوق راسه خيمه واللي
اليوم متاح بكره ما نعرف لو ممكن وكفايه
انه نتجزا وخلاص صاروا وقت ولو لمره واحده
انه نتوحد كتار شافوا في تغريده اصاله هذه
رد على اليسا ونزلت على العناوين انه
بتقول انه اصاله تهاجم اليسارا وان قال
خلاص ولعت حرب بارده بين اليسا واصاله
ويمكن عشان كده رجعت غردت اصاله بعدها
ووضحت وقالت الاختلاف في الاراء ما يعني
انه بنزعل من بعض اليسا حبيبتي رفيقتي
وارد بين الاصحاب الخلاف بالاراء وحتى
المبادئ اليسا ما ردت اي رد مباشر ولا
ذكرت اسم اصاله ابدا لكنها غرضت كلام غير
مباشره وقالت انه الحقيقه غريبه الناس
كثير كيف الانسان بيلغي كل شيء حلو وبيركز
على شيء اصلا فاهمه غلط على العموم مش
مشكلتي في ناس شافت الكلام اصاله او عفوا
الكلام اصاله هي اللي مقصوده فيه والناس
قالت لا هي بتتكلم عموما وعموما من ساعات
غردت اصاله كمان تغريده جديده كتبت فيها
انه احلى بلد في العالم هو لبنان
[موسيقى]
وبالتزامن مع يوم الصحه العالمي اطلقت
صحيفه الرياضيات تابعه للمجموعه السعوديه
للابحاث والنشر او مبادره رياضيه مبتكره
في السعوديه بهدف التشجيع على ممارسه
الرياضه والمبادره هي ببساطه ملاعب مطبوعه
وهذه المبادره خلت الرياضيه اول صحيفه في
العالم يمكن او يمكن ممارسه الرياضه عليها
وهذا الشيء بالتزامن مع يوم الصحه العالمي
وكما ذكرنا والتشجيع على الابتعاد عن او
عن الروتين المعتاد وممارسه النشاط البدني
كلام حلو وجميل بس اكيد كثار منكم الان
بيتسائلوا الملاعب مطبوعه كيف خلينا نشوف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ملاعب صحيفه الرياضيه المطبوعه زارها
المئات اوريدي ولسه متاحه امام الجميع
لاستخدامها وحقيقه يعني تحيه للزملاء في
الصحيفه على الفكره المبتكره والمبادره
المختلفه
كل سنه وترند المسلسلات الاقل من 30 حلقه
في عالم الدراما العربيه بدا يدخل وشفنا
اعمال كثيره من هذا النوع والسنه الماضيه
بدانا نشوف في رمضان مسلسلات من 15 حلقه
كمان وهذه السنه الموضوع مكمل وفي اعمال
منها دوله بداوا مع اول رمضان وخلصوا وفي
اعمال ثانيه لسه بادئه من كم يوم بالتزامن
مع 15 رمضان خلونا نستعرض مع بعض هذه
الاعمال
اللي شفناها هي الاعمال اللي بدا عرضها من
اعمال ال 15 حلقه لكن في ثلاث مسلسلات من
15 حلقه بدات مع اول رمضان وانتهت خلاص
اولها مسلسل واخيرا للنجمين قصي خولي
ونادين نسيم والقدير ومجموعه نجوم اخرين
ومسلسل الهرش السابعه اللي حكينا عنه
بدايه الحلقه من بطوله امينه خليل ومحمد
شاهين واسماء جلال وعلي قاسم ومجموعه نجوم
اخرين والمسلسل الثالث اللي من 15 كمان
حلقه وانتهى عرضه ومسلسل وعود سخيه للنجمه
حنان مطاوع واللي محظوظين بانها منورتنا
اليوم في استوديو تفاعلكم في الفقره
الجايه
[موسيقى]
حماده
قسما بالله العلي العظيم لاخليهم يتمنوا
الموت ما
يلاقوه والمسلسل على فكره عمل تفاعل كبير
خلال عرضه وبعده والسبب النهايه الماساويه
اللي ما ابغى احرجها للي ما تفرج خلال عرض
المسلسل الناس تفاعلت كثير كمان مع مشاهد
وجمل لسخيه صارت مثل الحكم
وعود سخيه خلص لكن حنان لسه مكمله معنا
رمضان في سر البعثه الملحمه التاريخيه
اللي بيخرجها خالد يوسف لاول مره في
الدراما وبتشكل عودته فيها بتلعب دور
صافيه القوي الصلبه الثائر المثابره واللي
بينه وبين السلطان حامد اللي هو احمد صلاح
السعدني علاقه حب كبير
[ضحك]
حلمت بحبك
كنت لازم تسالوا عن الارض تيجي قبل ما
تيجوا تشوفوا طحنه فيها كم معتدي ودفعنا
وان كان في وعود سخيه او سر الباتع مثل
العاده الاشادات بتلاحق حنان مطاوع في اي
عمل
في الاستوديو من بعد طول انتظار النجمه
على المطاوع اهلا فيك يا حنان منورتنا
اليوم اخيرا معانا يا فرحه قلبي والله
مبسوطه جدا احنا دايما كنا نتقابل عن بعد
بالواتساب وبالتليفونات وكده اخيرا عندي
النت وحش قوي في البيت وكنت بعمل مستحيل
علشان اطلع معك اخيرا الحمد لله
في دبي اول شي طبعا مبروك عملين يعني مهمه
جدا يعني بس مختلفين كمان جدا بتحبي نحكي
عن وعود سخريه اول ولا سر الباتع اول
والله الاثنين ولادي زي ما انت عايزه طب
خلينا نبتدي بوعود سخيه لانه
مختلف مختلف انت انت غيرتي جلدك فيه يعني
او انا كده حسيت هل هذا الانطباع صحيح
عندي ده حقيقي او كانت محاوله مني ان انا
اغير جلدي وكنت فرحانه جدا
بالتفاعل بتاع الناس في الشارع كمان يعني
ما كنتش متخيله خالص ان المسلسل هيتشاف لل
القهاوي تبقى فاتحه
والناس تبقى متابعه وعايزه تعرف كل يوم
متشوقه عايزه تعرف
المنشور هيعمل ايه حماده
رجبيه يعني حفظه الاسماء حتى بتاعه
الشخصيات فكنت فرحانه جدا
السخيه هو اسم منتشر وبشكل عام ولا لا صح
لا خالص وانا كمان المؤلف اول ما اختاره
قلت له سخيه اكيد هنغيره مش كده يعني وجاه
مكتوب باسم سخيف يعني حتى انا لما جات لي
فكره او يعني تركيبه الشخصيه وطلبت انا
عايزه اعمل الشخصيه الفلانيه للاستاذ
المؤلف فهو مشكورا حطها في الفكره بتاعته
دي
فاختار اسم سخيه قلت له ايه سخيه في حد
اسمه سخيه اصلا
بس بعد حلقه او اثنين حسيت انه مثير
للدهشه او للتساؤل اوكي
للاهتمام حسيت انه كده طيب بس المسلسل
كمان يعني برضه من الاعمال اللي هي خلينا
نقول انه قصيره يعني او ما بتستمر طول
الشهر وانت السنه الماضيه كان عندك برضه
تجربه نوعا ما مماثله عملتي 15 حلقه
وبعدين رجعتي 15 حلقه موضوع مختلف تاني
لقيتي هذا الشيء بيناسبك اكثر
لا هي مش حكايه بيناسبني هي كانت ظروف
العمل بتاعه السنه اللي فاتت
عملنا 15 ونزلناهم او يعني طلبنا ان احنا
انا طلبت ان احنا ننزلهم في رمضان
فالحقناهم ب 15 تانيين
السنه دي لضيق الوقت دخلنا ب 15 بس
الحقيقه انه ال 15 حلقه بتبقى موجزه جدا
بتبقى
بتمنع المشاهد من الملل
بتبقى مشوقه اكتر بالذات لو تم ايجادتها
بتكون كده مترابطه ايوه طيب انت اللي يعني
يعرفك في الطبيعه بيشوف كيف بتتكلمي سخيه
ما بتتكلم كذا
انت كده
كيف كيف الردح ده صراحه
ولا هو موهبه كامله كانت بالداخله
ولقيتيها فرصه تطلع ولا ايش ايوه نفسي
تتخانق ايوه لا يا حبيبتي انا دايما بحس
انه الفنان جواه ودائما بقولها جواه
كاميرا بيرصد الاخرين وبيصورهم وبيختزلهم
جواهم
بيختزن الوديع
والاسي والشرس
والطبقات مختلفه من المجتمع واهم حاجه انك
تبقي حاسه بيهم وما تقدميهمش بشكل قشري او
شكلي ده انت كمان بتبقي مصوراهم من جواهم
بتصوري اوجعهم وافرحهم
وانزلاقهم ونجاحتهم همم علشان تقدري تعبري
عنهم باريحيه فكل الصور دي موجوده جوايا
بشكل ما يعني النماذج دي انا شفتها بشكل
او باخر من راجل او من ست هي مش لازم
شخصيه بعينها بس كل النماذج دي انا
قابلتهم قابلتهم سواء عن قرب
او سواء ملمح كده خارجي فلما بتجيلي بقى
شخصيه بتطلع كل الشخصيات اللي انا صورتها
جوايا وحملتها جوه قلبي
وبحاول اطلع منها بقى مع جزء تخيلي برده
لا لا هو انت كنت مقنعه زياده عن اللزوم
صراحه انا قلت
خلينا هنعرض لك الان فيديو كمان انت
نشرتيه خلينا نشوفه مع بعض ونرجع نتكلم
عنه يلا
علامك وظيفتك قرشك هم سلاحك
اوعي تبكي على واحد مسكرتك اغلى منه
اتفقنا
علامك وظيفتك قرشك هم سلاحك
اوعي تبكي على واحد مسكرتك اغلى منه من
جواك السخيه عايزه تطلع دلوقتي
[ضحك]
نصائح دي ايش وضعها
عشان ابقى امينه طبعا هي
البنوته الجميله جدا اللي ماسكاه لي
سوشيال ميديا اقترحت هذا الفيديو لانه
كانت سخيه وقتها
كان تقريبا ده يوم تسعه رمضان مش تقريبا
او كانت يعني جايبه قوي مع الناس يعني
واكله التعليقات كتير كتير
عايزين نقول حاجه سخيه ستايل فقلت لها لا
انا ما بعرفش اعمل ده خالص فقلتها وبعدين
اخاف ادي نصيحه ما هو اصل السخيه دي برضه
يعني دماغها مش كويسه خالص يعني موده
البنت الصغننه في حته مش كويسه فقلت لها
انا ما اقدرش برضه يعني
يعني اقول كلمه الكلمه مسؤوليه يعني فقلت
طب هحاول قد ايش عندك كده ضمير
هتكتبي لي
استاذ خالد يوسف مشكورا لما كلمني انا كنت
بحضر لمسلسل ليا اسمه كفر العميان هو
المسلسل ده اتاجل كان 30 حلقه وكنا شغالين
على السكريبت ولانه كان شويه في سحر
وشعوذه ففي جرافيكس فعاديين بنحضر له
وازاي ما يبقاش ساذج وبتاع
فعرض عليا المسلسل وما كانش لسه بعت لي
السكريبت ده كان من التليفون قلت له يعني
يشرفني وكل حاجه ان انا نفسي اعمل حاجه
لبلدي بس
يعني يا اما اعمل سر الباتا يا اما اعمل
مسلسلي فقال لي لا ما تقلقيش هننسق قلت له
ايوه انا معرفش ادخل الاثنين في انون واحد
كده وعايزه كل واحد قال لي ما تقلقيش خالص
وشاء القدر ان انا فعلا دخلت سر البيت
وحضرته ذاكرته ابتديت اصوره وكفر العميان
ما بيدخلش واتاجلت اتاجلت ايه لان استاذ
ممدوح شاهين المنتج كلمني وقال لي بما انه
مسلسلك اتاجل فانا محتاجك في 15 حلقه
تعليم فكر في فكره سريعه وندخل نعملها طيب
بس الناس وحتى يمكن خلينا في عندنا بوست
للمخرج خالد يوسف هو كان بيقول انه خلينا
نشوفها على الشاشه الان البوست اللي نزلوا
طبعا مخرج العمل خالد يوسف قال بوست في حب
احمد السعدني وحنان مطاوع انا واقع في
غرام قصه حب صافيه والسلطان حامد منذ فكرت
فيها وكتبتها وعندما جسدتها وعندما جسدها
مثلا الحنان والسعدني وقعت في غرامها اكثر
يعني الناس طايحه في قصه الغرام هو في حب
كده يا حنان اه طبعا فيه اه طبعا اه طبعا
انا فرحانه جدا طبعا بالبوست ده انا بعثت
له على طول برده في حب الاستاذ خالد
وشيرت نفس المشهد اللي هو شيروه
الحقيقه اذا كانت الشخصيه او الشخصيتين
سلطان حامد وصافيه طلعوا حلوين فده بسبب
استاذ خالد الحقيقه وسبب
ده ابو معانا والمساحه اللي ادهالنا ان
احنا نبدع فيها الحقيقه اذا كان هو في ناس
بتقول عليه ديكتاتور انا ما شفتش ده مع
الممثل انا كان مدينا هامش رائع حتى في
الارتجال المشاهد في مشهد اللي احنا بنجري
واحنا اطفال وبيقطع علينا واحنا كبار
المشهد ده كان مكتوب ان احنا بنضحك بس
وكانت على
البيت اللي بيتهد وصباع حامد اللي بيطير
اقترحت على استاذ خالد ليه ما يبقاش فيه
ان انا بعلمه
القراءه والكتابه بشكل لذيذ وهو يعلمني
التحطيب لانها بنت قويه
فقال لي هتقولوا ايه فقام احمد قال طب ما
تيجي يعني احمد السعدني اقترح فكره انه
نقول
به تحتيها صحن تحتيه نقطه يبقى ايه
اللي هو البيه حرف الباء
وشكل البط هيبقى وارتجلناها فهو ضحك وقال
حبيتكم يلا صوروها مثلا انا بديكي مثال من
قد ايه هو كان بيخلينا
نطلع ونختلق في الشخصيه بما لا يتنافى مع
رؤيته وفي انسجام بينك وبين السعدني يعني
احمد انت علاقه قديمه يعني اصلا صحيح اه
طبعا لا ده اخويا احمد السعدني ده اخويا
منذ الصغر انا مستعجبه ان ده اول عمل لينا
طبعا انا مش انه اول عمل انا بالنسبه لي
ده حماده
فكنت مرتاحه جدا وانا بشتغل معاه ده غير
ان هو فنان مبدع جدا
ملتزم جدا وخلوق جدا فكنت حاسه ان انا مع
اخويا في اللوكيشن حقيقي
وشفتي طبعا اكيد يعني اي عمل زي ما في
كمان كلام كويس في كمان بعض الانتقادات
بعض الناس قالوا انه رساله
المسلسل عن الهويه المصريه مباشره زياده
عن اللزوم وتتذكري وقت قاهره
نفس الشيء خصوصا كان بيلعب وقتها
الفنان الكبير طبعا نبيل الحلفاوي برضو
الدور فقالوا انه يعني في كلام مباشر وكذا
احسوا الناس بعض الشيء نفس الشيء في هذا
المسلسل بتحسي هذا الشيء ولا بتحسي انه لا
هو المفروض يكون مباشر
دايما هرد الرد اللي رديته وقت القاهره يا
ابو المدام الناس حست بكده يبقى الناس صح
انا دايما مع الراي الجامعي كان او
الاغلبيه لكن انا بشوف انه الفن وجهه نظر
تتفق او تختلفي معها كان من حق استاذ خالد
يوسف انه يختار اللغه دي للتخاطب مع
الجمهور هو اختار في الوقت ده في الحقبه
دي يمكن الشكل
المباشر لصحصحه
الضمير الجمعي او الاحساس بالوطنيه احيانا
انت بتبقي محتاجه ده احيانا بتبقي محتاجه
شكل مباشر يفوقك انك تحبي امك او انك تحبي
صديقتك او انك تحبي جيرانك احيانا انا مش
شايفه ان هو مباشر مش قادره اشوفها لكن لو
الناس شايفه كده فالناس على صواب انت
دائما متزنه كده
ههه عشان احتاج اسجل معك كورسات لانه يعني
انت بتضحكيني يا ساره بس على فكره والله
العظيم لانه حتى لو سجلت معك كورسات برضو
حارسب في كل
طيب ما بتزعلي احد يعني الناس قالوا في
اخطاء مثلا حكايه انه الشوز الحديث اللي
ظهرت في المعاري كل الاشياء دي كلها هذه
ايش مثلا تحسي تحسي تصيد للعمل مثلا لما
تكون نتكلم والله انا شفت يعني شفت اعمال
عالميه ضخمه رائعه
للمخرجين عظماء كان فيها غلطه راكورات
الحقيقه يعني احنا عندنا كارثه اسمها
سوشيال ميديا ممكن تعملي
كلوسب على لحظه تقعدي تعملي زوم زوم زوم
زوم زوم
انا شفت بعيني 500 كومبارس 500 جندي
وفي مشاهد يا مثلا مشهد محاكمه السلطان
حامد محاكمه السلطان حامد دي اتعملت في
اربع ايام مشهد يعني احنا بنعمل دلوقتي في
الصناعه كان جامعكم كلكم كلكم احنا دلوقتي
في المسلسلات بنعمل بالعشرين مشهد في
اليوم فان احنا نقعد في مشهد اربع ايام
عايزه اقول لك الاتقان بس وارد قوي انه
يبقى واحد من الكومبارسات رجله وجعته
واحنا بنصور 12 ساعه والدنيا بارده او
الدنيا شمس على حسب
في يوم قلع الجزمه ولبس جزمه ثانيه حقيقي
ممكن يبقى محدش خد باله انها يعني حقيقي
في اخطاء لو حد جه معانا اللوكيشن وشاف
الدنيا بيت ودار ازاي هيعرف انه انك تعملي
كنترول طول الوقت صعب لكن
حتى لو في اخطا ما دام الناس شافت ان في
اخطاء يبقى في اخطاء بس في ايجابيات كمان
في عمل كبير انا مش معقوله ابقى بصه لك
اقول لك معلش الشعرايه دي طالعه وما اشوفش
قد انت جميله في كل حاجه في لبقتك في
كلامك في الكلام حقيقي ده حقيقي ده مش
مثال بقى على فكره انا مش مثال بس من
حنانه ده حنان بتقصده معايا انا بقصد وصل
وقتنا للنهايه للاسف انا بشكرك جدا على
وجودك معانا اليوم نورتينا نورتينا
نورتينا وانت عارفه على المستوى الشخصي قد
ايش احبك كانت معنى النجمه حنان مطاوع
ومشاهدينا انا اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء
الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]